you know Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling
but what about all those other familiar
faces in Barbie here's why all those
Barbie land residents look so familiar K
McKinnon is most recognizable as a
former cast member of Saturday Night
Live throughout her tenure on the show
she quickly became one of the most
iconic performers to ever grace the
halls of 30 Rock some of McKinnon's SNL
highlights include characters like Miss
Rafferty a woman recounting her
undesirable encounters with aliens and
Sheila a bar Patron who gets hot and
heavy with a fellow bar flies hey was
your mother a beaver cause damn you got
a flat tail furry face and smell like a
lake
although McKinnon only recently left
Saturday Night Live in 2022 she'd
already started steadily building a film
career for herself prior to leaving with
roles in the 2016 Ghostbusters reboot as
well as comedies like rough night The
Spy Who dumped me and yesterday given
her extensive comedy background as well
as her pension for playing strange
characters on Saturday Night Live she
was a perfect fit for weird Barbie the
outcast Barbie whom little girls play
with too hard speaking to Entertainment
Weekly on her visual inspiration for
weird Barbie McKinnon commented I just
pulled a bunch of pictures of the
internet I think I typed in like effed
up doll
and Bobby simu Leo is one of the most
significant Kens in the film rivaling
Ryan Gosling's Ken for Bobby's attention
and even engaging in an extravagant 80s
steam dance battle during the film's
climax for audiences who aren't aware of
Liu's prior work they might have been
surprised to see this can perform
numerous backflips throughout the film
which no other Ken can replicate however
this is all in the day's work for Leo
prior to the mainstream success of
Barbie Leo was mostly known for
appearing in the 2021 Marvel Cinematic
Universe film Xiang Chi and the legend
of the ten Rings playing the titular
martial art system is forced to confront
his father the leader of a vast criminal
organization dad please
your family needs you Liu notably
performed as many of his own stunts as
possible as Shang Chi which was no easy
feat to master for the role he taught
Entertainment Weekly I want to sit here
and tell you that I was pretty good at
martial arts before but really my
martial arts experience was like back
flipping in my backyard when I was a
teenager and doing parkour with my
friends aside from his work in the world
of Marvel Leo also gains notoriety for
starring in the Canadian sitcom Kim's
Convenience and also appeared in the
2023 romantic drama one true loves
opposite Philippa Sue however Liu will
likely look back on Barbie as a
formative experience and is so far short
but promising career in Hollywood
Issa Ray first gained everybody's
attention with a self-produced internet
web series to Misadventures of awkward
black girl which was later adapted into
the successful HBO Comedy insecure
created by and starring Rey it follows a
woman navigating social life romance and
contemporary life for an
African-American woman we are not about
to be the black couple fighting in
writing the series was the recipient of
many Emmy nominations and launched right
into the Limelight as one of the most
talked about young creative minds of the
2010s insecure concluded its run on HBO
in 2021 but Reyes remained busy ever
since in 2020 she flexed her acting
Reign for the romantic drama the
photograph and the romantic comedy the
lovebirds on the TV side of things Rey
has also appeared in various sketches on
HBO's of black ladies sketch show which
he also executive produces and hosted
Saturday Night Live in 2020. more
recently Ray lent her voice to 2023's
Spider-Man across the spider-verse as
Jessica Drew AKA Spider Woman in Barbie
Issa Rae plays President Barbie who
unlike Margot Robbie's stereotypical
Bobby becomes victim to the Ken's
brainwashing after Gosling's Ken takes
over Barbie land and the film scenes
about Womanhood Rey told girls United
it's really just up to you about how you
want to present and how you want people
to see you America Ferreira has a unique
role in Barbie compared to most other
cast members rather than play a resident
of Barbie land Ferreira plays Gloria a
hard-working mother employed as a
secretary at Mattel whose existential
crisis results in her playing with her
daughter's Barbie creating a dimensional
riff that brings Margot Robbie's Barbie
into the real world Ferreira also gets
the privilege of delivering perhaps the
best monologue in the film ranting to
the Barbies about the contradictory
expectations placed on women in the real
world although some audiences may be
delightfully surprised by just how much
Ferrera steals a show True fans of the
actress have known her strengths for
years her film debut was in 2002's real
women have curves which has been
regarded by many to be one of the most
influential films of the 2000s for his
depiction of Latino women I'm not your
baby anymore more
since then Ferrara has starred in The
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants and
its sequel the dry land and voices
Astrid in the How to Train Your Dragon
franchise ferrera's breakthrough however
came by starring in the lead role in
ABC's Ugly Betty centering on a girl who
lacks style but gets employed at a
fashion magazine after running for Four
Seasons before getting canceled in 2010
Ferreira then starred an executive
produced in NBC's sitcom Superstore for
six seasons as the floor manager of a
fictional department store called Cloud9
in Bobby Alexandra Ship plays a Nobel
prize-winning writer Barbie who is the
first Barbie to be cured of the
brainwashing from the Kens thanks to
Glorious rantabouts how unfair the
expectations put on women are according
to the actress being a part of Barbie's
World was a dream come true telling out
about how walking onto set for the first
time completely overwhelmed her she said
it was so massive enough to scale that
the little girl in me started just
crying that's High Praise from ship who
has quite a stacked resume for such a
young up-and-comer in the world of film
she first gained recognition for trained
the singer Aliyah in the 2014 Lifetime
movie Aaliyah the princess of r b later
making notable appearances in films like
NWA biopic Straight Outta Compton lgbtq
plus rom-com loves Simon and coming of
age drama dude throughout the late 2010s
she also entered the X-Men universe as a
mutant storm in the 2016 film X-Men
apocalypse which she reprized in 2019's
dark Phoenix ship later received
recognition for appearing in the 2021
musical biopic Tick Tick boom which
stars Andrew Garfield as playwright and
composer Jonathan Larson Emma Mackey's
presence in Barbie alongside Margot
Robbie was a long time coming
considering how much the two actors were
told they looked like each other in fact
there was meant to be a joke referencing
their similarity in the film but Robbie
said in an interview with BuzzFeed once
we got all dressed up as our Barbies we
were kind of like we don't look that
similar however Mackie still stands out
as physicist Barbie yet another role in
her steadily increasing resume in
Hollywood most audiences came to know
Maki through her role as Maeve in the
Netflix series sex education mackie's
performance in the show's second season
was notably critically acclaimed
eventually leading to a rich career in
film starting with the 2021 French
romance Eiffel Mackie also appeared in
the 2022 mystery death on the Nile
directed by Kenneth Branagh and based on
Agatha Christie's novel of the same name
also in 2022 Mackie appeared in Emily a
biopic from Francis O'Connor starring
Maki as writer Emily Bronte in a
performance at New York Times called
Mercurial and mesmerizing
Charlotte says all the people in the
village call me the strange one
the further Acclaim Mackie received from
the film eventually led to her winning
The bafta Rising Star Award at the
British Academy's 2023 awards ceremony
so for those who enjoyed mackie's role
in Barbie get used to seeing her in the
future
Kingsley benedir has had a short yet
prosperous career in Hollywood so far
though his experience in performing
Shakespearean theater in the early 2010s
has made him a tour de force of an actor
he first rose to mainstream prominence
in seasons 4 and 5 of the BBC period
drama peaky blinders which was followed
up by prominent roles in series like the
OA High Fidelity and zakomi rule the
latter of which saw him appear as former
president Barack Obama in film he
appeared in one night in Miami playing
Malcolm X no sex said that if I decide
to leave the Nation of Islam I will be
doing so on my own most recently benadir
has completely stolen the show in the
latest Marvel Cinematic Universe series
secret Invasion where he stars as gravic
the leader of a group of Rebel Scrolls
who seek to take over planet Earth after
growing tired of Nick Fury's failed
promise to find them a new home
somewhere in the Galaxy however
benedir's role in Barbie is a huge
departure from his character in the
Marvel Universe menedia plays a Ken and
like all the other Ken's he's desperate
for the attention of Barbies which
coincides with the actor's own desire to
be in the film as he told variety it's
very rare that a script like that comes
along so I was like whatever whoever is
in it I just want to be on set with
those guys and I want to be a part of it
if Scott Evans looks recognizable then
maybe because you mistaken him for his
brother actor Chris Evans known for his
performances as Captain America and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as well as
films like knives house and The Gray Man
[Music]
Scott stars and Barbie is a Ken who
fights for the side of simu Liu's Ken
while also having some obnoxious
thoughts about finance that one of the
Barbies tricks him into telling her
Evan's career began on daytime
television starring in the ABC soap
opera One Life to Live as Oliver Fish a
police officer whose lgbtq plus
storyline caused some onset controversy
Evans ended up playing the role of
Oliver for another two years before he
was eventually written out of the show
in 2010 since then Evans has had many
successful acting roles plus a cameo in
2014's playing it cool starring his
brother Chris in 2020 Evan starred in
the dramedy almost love however nothing
in the actor's career so far is stacked
up to working with Gerwig he told else I
was in a state of panic the entire time
just a huge sense of imposter syndrome
knowing who else was a part of the movie
Somebody went to see Barbie may not have
recognized shooting as Ken but that will
soon change the Rwandan Scottish actor
portrays a goatee Ken who fights
alongside Ryan Gosling's Ken and
Kingsley benedizken in the Battle of
Cairns like Ben adir gatoa got his start
in Shakespearean theater before coming
to wider Acclaim with his role in sex
education which he stars in alongside
Barbie co-stars Emma Maki and Connor
swindells he also had an appearance in
the Netflix movie the last letter from
your lover although his performance as
Eric the best friend of Otis in sex
education won gatwa a bafta Scotland
Award for best actor in television his
breakthrough role is yet to come in 2022
it was announced that Gasper would be
succeeding Jody Whitaker as the latest
incarnation of the doctor and the iconic
Sci-Fi series Doctor Who although he was
initially announced to be the 14th
doctor a surprise twist at the end of
Whitaker's final episode showed her
doctor transforming into David Tennant's
version of the character with gatoa
clarified to actually be the 15th doctor
gato won't make his day you as a dog
Drew until a series of anniversary
specials in 2023 before the 14th season
of the Sci-Fi Revival debuts in 2024
Curry Neff is a standout of the Barbie
cast playing the role of Dr Bobby who
also moonlights as a DJ for Barbie's
dreamhouse dance party at the beginning
of the movie however the role is far
from her first breakthrough as nephilis
had a groundbreaking career thus far as
both an actress and a model after
appearing on the cover of a 2016 issue
of L Neff made history as a first openly
transgender woman to appear on a
mainstream British magazine I like to
think that if like my secrets ever got
aired I would just be like yeah what
about it as an actress Nev first rose to
prominence in the Amazon Prime video
drama transparent which centers on a
family dealing with a revelation that
their patriarch played by Jeffrey tumble
is a trans woman Neff went on to Star
and other popular shows like you The
Marvelous Mrs maisel and most recently
in 2023 the controversial HBO drama
series the idol in the film World
Netflix had many notable appearances
since a breakthrough role in transparent
she has appeared in 2018's assassination
Nation the gaming comedy one up and
peacocks meet cute
Jamie dimitriu first gained notoriety in
the UK as a comedian appearing in Phoebe
water Bridges critically acclaimed 2016
series fleabag as bus rodent although
dimitriu doesn't support bus rodents
horrid teeth in real life it was a
memorable performance for many given
that the comedian is now asked to reveal
his tease to strangers since his
performance in fleabag Demetrio has seen
much success in both the UK and across
the pond in 2018 he created co-wrote and
starred in the sitcom staff lets Flats
playing an incompetent London letting
agent Demetrius work in the show netted
him a triple win at the baftas in 2020
for writing performing and producing his
work has remained extensive since that
lets Flats ended in 2021. he appeared in
season 1 of the Apple TV plus mystery
the after party as a forgettable world
and also appeared in tbs's miracle
workers in 2023 he wrote and created a
Netflix sketch comedy special titled a
whole lifetime with Jaime Demetrio in
Barbie Dimitri who plays second fiddle
to Will Ferrell as a CFO of Mattel a
perfect fit for Demetrius awkward style
of humor though she's still a teenager
Ariana Greenblatt has built up an
impressive resume in Barbie she
impressed audiences of Sasha the
daughter of America ferrara's Gloria who
is disenchanted by the idea of Barbie
and remains critical of Margot Robbie's
character until later having a change of
heart after she sees Barbie slowly
become human before that Greenblatt Rose
to prominence on the Disney Channel
sitcom Stuck in the Middle co-starring
alongside Jenna Ortega Greenblatt
transitioned to film quickly after
debuting and stuck in the middle
including appearances in a bad Moms
Christmas love and monsters and in the
Heights she even made a Marvel Cinematic
Universe debut in 2018's Avengers
Infinity War playing a younger version
of Gamora during a flashback sequence in
which he's adopted by The Mad Titan
Thanos you're quite the fighter Gamora
come
let me help you more recently Greenblatt
has appeared in two sci-fi Thrillers
awake starring Gina Rodriguez and
2023-65 starring Adam Driver the latter
of which finds the two sharing most of
the screen time as the only humans on a
strange remote planet that is actually
prehistoric Earth
[Music]